The equation for line A is x equals 2, and the equation for line B is y equals
negative 5. Let's talk about why. Remember that along any vertical line, every
single point has the same x value. The y values are going to range everywhere
negative infinity all the way to positive infinity. But the x one it stays
constant along that entire range. So, this is the only equation that we can
write that fits every point along that line. There's a similar deal for line B
and other horizontal lines. But regarding their y-coordinates instead of their
x-coordinates. We said that every point along a horizontal line has the same y
value. Its x values go from negative infinity to positive infinity. But the only
equation that accurately describes every point along the line is y equals
negative 5. Vertical and horizontal lines then have sort of special equations
because they only have one variable in them. This is pretty different from
equations of other lines we've seen, like for example y equals 3 x minus 2. Here
we have an x and y in the same equation. What these equations show is,
respectively, that for vertical lines, this relation with x is going to be true
regardless of y value. And for horizontal lines, this equation involving y is
going to be true regardless of x value, or for any x value.